♪ ♪
>> Trey: THE SPECIAL EDITION
OF "HANNITY."
BEFORE WE GO I WANT TO TELL YOU
ABOUT MY NEW BOOK "DOESN’T HURT
TO ASK TO COMMUNICATE AND
PERSUADE."
IT’S NOT WHAT I BELIEVE BUT WHAT
YOU PROVE YOU BELIEVE.
IS OUT NEXT WEEK AND IT WILL
HELP YOU MAKE YOUR CASE AND MOVE
OTHERS CLOSE TO A NEW WAY OF
THINKING.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
SEAN WILL BE BACK ON MONDAY,
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" IS UP NEXT.
HAVE A GREAT WEEK.
>> ON TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE" I
AM RAYMOND ARROYO SITTING IN FOR
LAURA.
I HAVE A LINEUP HE WILL NOT WANT
TO MISS.
WE TALKED TO CHICAGO ALDERMAN
WHO NOT ONLY AT HIS HOME BUT HIS
OFFICE WAS RANSACKED, AND HE
WILL COME HERE TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE GROUND.
WE HAVE A MAYOR AND LOCAL
PROSECUTORS WHO ARE FAILING TO
ACT AND WE WILL ALSO TALK WITH
THE COLLEGE STUDENT AS WELL AS
EXPERTS ON COVID IN WHAT IS
HAPPENING AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL.
AND LATER WE WILL TAKE YOU
INSIDE THAT TRUNK DEAL THAT UAE
ISRAELI DEAL.
IT IS AN AMAZING LINEUP.
PLEASE STAY WITH US, BUT FIRST,
MY THOUGHTS ON UNIVERSITIES AND
WHAT IS HAPPENING THERE.
UNITED WE STAND, DIVIDED WE
SNITCH.
IN ADDITION TO THE LOCKDOWNS AND
THE MASK MANDATE, PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEE JOE BIDEN HAS ONE, BIG
COVID PLAN.
>> INDIVIDUAL STATES LIKE
NEW YORK AND CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HIRING TRILLIONS OF THOUSANDS OF
TRACING.
BUT WE NEED TO DO MORE INCLUDING
HIRING 1,000 FEDERALLY FUNDED
WORKERS WITH CONTACT TRACING AND
OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH HABITS.
THEY SHE BEGAN TO BE TRAINED
NOW.
IT’S BEEN WHEN THEY ARE BEING
TRAINED BY THE THOUSANDS TO
TRACK YOUR WHEREABOUTS AND CUTE
GUY WHO YOU’VE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH, AND A PERSON TO.
TRACERS TO HELP THE RECORDING
ALL OF YOUR INTERACTIONS.
NOW, THIS IS A TRACER/TRAINER IN
HOUSTON.
>> THERE HAS BEEN PLENTY OF
PEOPLE FROM THIS THAT THEY WOULD
LOSE THEIR JOBS.
AND THEY DON’T WANT TO GET ANY
KIND OF INFORMATION THAT WE
DON’T ALREADY HAVE IN OUR HANDS.
>> LIBERAL GOVERNORS AND MAYORS
HAVE MOSTLY WAVED OFF PRIVACY
CONCERNS.
THEY HAVE NOT ONLY EMBRACED THE
TRACING REGIMENT, BUT THEY HAVE
TAKEN ENFORCEMENT OF THEIR
HEALTH ORDERS A STEP FURTHER.
IN MARYLAND, BASHAR OF KENTUCKY
SET UP HOTLINES TO WAIVERS.
SPEAK WITH THOSE NOT IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE
ORDERS, THIS IS A CALL THAT CAN
ALLOW GOVERNMENT TO KNOW TO MAKE
THAT WE KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW.
>> Raymond: L.A.
MAYOR GARCETTI WAS MORE EXPLICIT
EXPLICIT.
>> YOU KNOW THE OLD EXPRESSION
ABOUT SNITCHES COMING IN THIS
CASE, SNITCHES GET REWARDS.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU FOR TURNING
FOLKS IN AND MAKING SURE WE ARE
ALL SAFE.
THEY WENT TURNING FOLKS AND THAT
SNITCH MIND-SET HAS HIT
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS AMERICA.
TO RETURN TO CAMPUS COMMITTEES
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE REQUIRED TO
SIGN CONTRACTS WITH THEIR
SCHOOLS PROMISING TO ABIDE BY
NEW COVID REQUIREMENTS.
MASS WEARING SOCIAL DISTANCING,
EATING ALONE IN SOME CASES,
ROUTINE TESTING, NO OVERNIGHT
STORM PARTIES NOTHING.
VIOLATORS FACE SUSPENSION OR
EXPULSION.
BUT HOW DO THEY ENFORCE THE
COVID CONTRACTS ON CAMPUS?
ENTER THE WELLNESS AMBASSADORS.
>> TO YOU PUBLIC HEALTH
INVESTORS, VOLUNTEER STUDENTS,
FACULTY AND STAFF WILL MODEL AND
MONITORED AS A PLANNING PRACTICE
IS.
>> THE UNIVERSITY IS ENCOURAGING
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS TO ABIDE BY
THE COVID GUIDELINES, AND
SOMETIMES WE MAY HAVE TO
ENFORCEMENT THESE GUIDELINES IF
PEOPLE DO NOT ABIDE BY THEM.
WE ALSO HAVE OUR WELLNESS
SUPPORT AMBASSADORS TO CHECK
COMPLIANCE AT THE ENTRANCES OF
ALL OF OUR BUILDINGS AND OUR
CLASSROOMS.
>> Raymond: SO WELLNESS
SUPPORT AMBASSADORS, WE WILL
CHECK YOUR PAPERS.
IT IS A LIBRARY.
THAT IS RIGHT.
YOU PAY 50 TO 60, SOMETIMES
$80,000 A YEAR TO HAVE YOUR KIDS
BASICALLY ENTER WHAT IS NOW A
SOVIET STYLE, PEOPLE’S REPUBLIC
OF EDUCATION.
WHERE THEY ARE PEERS ARE
ENCOURAGED TO SPY ON THEM AND
TURN THEM OVER TO
ADMINISTRATORS.
YOU MIGHT CALL IT SNITCH YOU.
IF YOU THINK I’M EXAGGERATING MY
BEAR IN MIND THE UNIVERSITIES
REQUIRE ALL RETURNING STUDENTS
TO TAKE COVID TEST BEFORE THEY
CAN ANSWER.
COLUMBIA IS RECRUITING STUDENT
AMBASSADORS TO HELP POLICE THE
STUDENT BODY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI IS
PAYING $10 AN HOUR FOR THEIR
PUBLIC HEALTH AMBASSADORS.
AND THEY ARE NOT ALONE.
A COLLEGE BUT TRAINING HEALTH
BINDERS AND LISTENING TO ON THE
STUDENT BODY.
TO CONFRONT ANYONE WHO IS NOT
WEARING A MASK OR SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND "IF THE PERSON
PERSISTS AND NOT COMPLYING OR
RESPONSE CONFRONTATIONAL WAY,
YOU SHOULD NOT PURSUE THE MATTER
FACE TO FACE BUT INSTEAD REPORT
THAT WAS STUDENTS
NONCOMPLIANCE."
THESE UNIVERSITIES ARE NOT
PLAYING AROUND.
>> WE NEED PEOPLE TO ADAPT THE
BEHAVIORS IMMEDIATELY.
I CAN TELL YOU, WE WILL PULL OUT
ALL THE STOPS FROM THE RESEARCH
EVIDENCE.
AND ALSO, WE WILL HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF EXPECTATION THAT THE
COMMUNITY WILL RESPOND IF OUR
GUIDANCE, THE THRESHOLD WILL BE
VERY, VERY LITTLE.
AND HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Raymond: NO QUESTION, WE
WILL EXPLORE SHORTLY AS WELL AS
A TEXAS STUDENT IS THIS WILL.
WHAT DID THE COVID STUDENTS HAVE
ON COMMUNITY COHESIVENESS?
DOESN’T UNDERLINE THE ACADEMIC
AND PERSONAL FREEDOM YOUNG
PEOPLE NEED FOR GROWTH,
INTELLECTUALLY AND SOCIALLY?
AND ARE OUR INSTITUTIONS OF